Jennifer Garner kicks butt in her new  movie peppermint but even someone as  athletic as Jen runs into the occasional  debacle we start feeling a current  pulling Jen told the story on Wednesdays  Tonight Show with Jimmy Fallon her 12  year old daughter Violet did a school  report on the country of Sweden she got  so into it she loved it so much and  she's like mom maybe I'm a socialist as  a reward for her hard work Jen took her  on a trip to Sweden they spent a day  kayaking which started off great but  quickly went awry violent my daughter  said mom there's a stoplight in the  water there's a stoplight and through  that stop like it's a lock to the ocean  [Laughter]  thankfully Jen had her cell phone and  called for help  we saw this blond human with the Sun  behind him like a halo and he was coming  to her rescue and he showed up and he  led us back and his name was my TAS my  never forget  [Music]